fox news alert millions of american
families could lose their
homes when the federal eviction
moratorium expires tonight at midnight
it took effect in march as part of the
cares act
for coronavirus relief now many experts
say
we are on the verge of a full-blown
eviction
crisis julian turner is live in
washington
with more jillian hi melissa so you're
right the federal government's ban on
evictions during
the pandemic is set to expire in just a
few hours
and now about 20 million american
families are facing the threat of being
kicked out of their homes it's something
experts have been bringing alarm bells
about in recent weeks because this month
alone
july 32 of american households missed
either their rent
or their mortgage payments it's a
staggering number experts also say
america's biggest cities are going to be
hit the worst that's where most renters
live exhibit a new york city take a
listen
we are about to go over a cliff here in
this city
in terms of people potentially losing
their housing and we have to stop it
los angeles is another potential hot
spot on the verge of crisis
even though i'm receiving unemployment
it's still not the same amount that i
was
before my rent is
about 30 percent of my income was before
the
pandemic democratic leadership wants to
include housing assistance in the next
coronavirus supplemental bill that's
working its way through capitol hill now
listen to chuck schumer if we pass
emergency rental assistance
and extend the evictions moratorium we'd
help families and individuals pay the
bills
stay in their homes stabilize the rental
market
and keep up help owners keep up with
their property taxes and mortgages
they claim more homelessness will mean
more sick americans here's elizabeth
warren
forcing thousands of people out of their
homes during a pandemic
will make a public health crisis worse
widespread housing disruptions will also
affect essential workers and others who
are keeping our economy
going neither schumer nor warren though
can resist dinging
republicans we are just
days away from a housing crisis
that could be prevented if mitch
mcconnell stops stalling
and the senate acts
now we've talked to republicans all
morning long over on capitol hill
and at the white house they all say
keeping americans in their homes is a
top priority for president trump and
mass scale evictions ain't going to
happen
on his watch melissa
we will see jillian turner thank you for
that